[Applaudissements]
la parole est à d'autres collègues à la
millions pour le groupe l'est
républicain et merci
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre les récentes révélations de
maltraitance protéiforme à l'égard des
résidents d pad gérée par plusieurs
groupes privés on provoque un tsunami
suscitant des réactions de toutes parts
et pourtant en 2014 et pourtant en 2014
claude evin alors directeur général de
la rs d'île de france avait alerté le
ministère de la santé sur des pratiques
de rétrocommissions dans des ehpad du
groupe korian ils réclamaient alors une
réforme d'ampleur de la tarification des
ehpad en octobre 2018 des représentants
syndicaux s'étant adressée au président
de la république pour lui signaler une
situation explosive
le rendez vous qui avait été fixé avec
une conseillère fut annulée
la ministre de la santé de l'époque
déblocage en urgence et 50 millions
d'euros mais s'inquiétait je cite d'une
forme de ehpad bashing le 30 janvier
2018 fut une journée de mobilisation des
personnels des ehpad qui dénonçaient
leurs conditions de travail
incompatibles avec la dignité qui devait
accompagner leurs missions et l'accueil
des résidents en ehpad en mars 2018 nos
collègues michelle meunier et bernard
bonne remettait d'un rapport dans lequel
il faisait 24 propositions pour apporter
des solutions immédiatement exploitable
est envisagé également une réforme
ambitieuse de la dépendance devenue
impérieuse des sonnettes d'alarmé tirées
à maintes reprises qu'ils se perdent et
non pas dans l'indifférence mais plutôt
dans la culpabilité d'une société qui
nous et regarder le sort réservé à ses
aînés madame la ministre pourquoi at il
fallu attendre la sortie de l'enquète de
ce journaliste pour entendre les voix
des personnels entendre leur désarroi
celui des résidents et celui des
familles
pour vous répondre
la parole est que la ministre déléguée
en charge de l'autonomie wallemme
bourguignon
monsieur le président le sénateur alain
milon ça me navre la façon dont vous
poser cette question permettez moi de
vous le dire parce que vous savez très
bien l'action que je mène depuis mon
arrivée et l'action j'ai mené en tant
que président des affaires sociales j'ai
été la première à demander un rapport
d'urgence sur les ehpad dès mon arrivée
en 2010 est depuis cette date nous
n'avons cessé de travailler avec les
acteurs et permettez-moi de vous
rappeler le plan ambitieux que nous
sommes en train de faire et que vous
avez voté d'ailleurs par ailleurs sur la
réforme autonomie que vous avez tous
salué sur ses bancs parce que vous le
savez bien c'est un secteur qui est en
grande difficulté et pas depuis cinq ans
depuis 20 ans depuis 15 ans avec
beaucoup d'acuité certains l'ont relevé
d'autres sous beaucoup plus nuancés dans
leurs propos en ce moment parce que
chacun doit balayer devant sa porte je
le souhaite vraiment il ne faut pas les
leurs en ce moment nous avons du
personnel en souffrance croyez-vous
qu'on le découvre nous avons des
familles aussi qu'il nous parle qui ce
qui témoigne et je voudrais être
aujourd'hui avec elle et vous dire
combien nous les entendons et donc nous
sommes en train de travailler mais dire
qu'il ne s'est rien passé entre temps
est inadmissible vous savez bien qu'il y
à des contrôles que ces contrôles sont
inopinées lorsqu'il y à des signalements
qu'il y en a pas assez mais c'est quand
même un peu ce serait ironique si
c'était pas si dramatique qu'aujourd'hui
des groupes qui agissent très mal
réclame des contrôles c'est les voleurs
qui veulent plus ces légendes un petit
qui veulent plus de gendarmes en gros
les voleurs volent plus de gendarmes
c'est inadmissible je trouve que
remettre le débat là où il doit être là
où il doit être c'est à dire que
lorsqu'il ya des groupes qui de manière
systémique omis un système en place eh
bien il faut le dénicher mais vous savez
comme moi monsieur millon vous êtes trop
à visé dans cette affaire que ces
contrôles sont des contrôles parcellaire
qu'il faut plusieurs pièces au puzzle
pour réunir et contrôler tout un système
est arrivé un système mais les contrôles
sont les établissements sont réalisés et
on ne peut pas laisser dire aujourd'hui
en france que ça n'est pas le cas donc
je crois qu'il faut remettre tout à plat
et bien entendre et surtout travailler
dans la sérénité et pas de cette manière
s'il vous plaît il y à deux contrôles
igas igf qui mettront la lumière sur
cette affaire et tout le reste doit être
reposée nous y travaillons pour
conforter et je vous invite à participer
à nos travaux
ses pions
oui merci monsieur le président madame
ministre quid quand même des contrôles
n'ont fait pourtant prescrit par la loi
quid d'une insuffisance de personnel
responsable de la maltraitance à
volontaires quid d'une diversité de
l'offre n'ont offert à nos anciens quid
d'une grande loi sur le grand âge
toujours promise jamais réalisé devenu
l'arlésienne c'est la mandature qui
vient doit être évidemment celle qui
doit faire en sorte que le grand âge
soit une grande cause nationale
[Applaudissements]